when the Buffalo Bills play their first
home game of the season on September
14th against the Miami Dolphin they will
be without their tear leaders the
buffalo jills for the first time since
1967
that's because a half dozen cheerleaders
are suing the team for wage stuff the
bills are not alone the New York Jets
Tampa Bay Buccaneers and Cincinnati
Bengals are also being sued by
cheerleaders claiming that the team's
failed to pay minimum wage the
cheerleaders say they were paid from
$150 to $0 per game and often no pay for
practices or off field appearances a
rate that sometimes came to less than $2
per hour NFL teams can get away with
this for two reasons first cheerleaders
have been putting up with it for years
hundreds of them try out every year for
one of about 35 spots on them now 25
teams that have cheerleading squads
second the team's claim that
cheerleaders are either seasonal workers
or independent contractors who under
federal law at least are not entitled to
a minimum wage these lawsuits however
could mean the end of the cheap NFL
cheerleader the NFL has an annual
revenue of 9.2 billion so does it make
sense to pay a sideline performer so
little in Buffalo for instance to pay
every Bills cheerleader the $8 hourly
minimum wage for 20 hours per week from
tryouts through the playoffs would cost
two hundred and thirty five thousand
dollars the lowest paid player on the
team who gets four hundred and twenty
thousand dollars a year to pay every
cheerleader in the NFL $10 an hour would
take about seven point six million
dollars that's less than a fifth of the
44 million dollars that NFL Commissioner
Roger Goodell took home in 2012
according to analysts cheerleaders
appear on TV screens for an average of
seven seconds per game that airtime is
worth eight and a quarter million
dollars per season with those kinds of
numbers minimum wage doesn't seem so
much to ask
you